Zoolander 2 is directed by Ben Stiller
and stars Ben Stiller and Owen Wilson
returning once again as Derek Zoolander
and Hansel Hansel so hot right now and
you may be thinking why the different
location Chris where are you filming or
changing things up are you moving no I'm
just filming in a different side of my
house for tonight and I'll talk more
about that after this video in this film
Derek Zoolander has lost his son because
Child Services has taken his son away
because obviously he's not fit to be a
parent so he's trying to get his son
back while also reentering the fashion
industry with his friend Hansel now if
you didn't know the first Zoolander is
actually one of my favorite comedies I
love that movie I watched that movie
evolve from a little scene comedy into
cult status
Zoolander is hilarious I could quote the
entire thing did you ever think that
maybe there's more to life than being
really really really ridiculously
good-looking mer man man man what is
this a center for ants yeah I could go
on and on and some of my longtime
viewers will probably remember my old
intro featuring me doing my own version
of blue steel so you guys get the point
I'm kind of a massive Zoolander fan
which is why I was very disappointed by
this movie because it's not good look I
didn't go to Zoolander 2 expecting a
mind-blowing experience I didn't go into
this film expecting a very smart film
because some films can be so dumb that
they're smart like the first Zoolander
or perhaps the first Dumb and Dumber I
went into this movie expecting it to be
funny and it just really wasn't that
often and that's my biggest flaw with
Zoolander 2 I just didn't laugh that
much which is so bad this movie should
have had me rolling in the aisles I
actually really liked Ben Stiller I like
Owen Wilson as well and there's a lot of
cast members in this film that I also
like and that are very talented and I've
liked basically all of Ben Stiller's
directorial work cable guys ok but
reality bites Tropic Thunder a Zoolander
the guy's a good director and I think
he's very funny this movie isn't that's
not to say there aren't parts where I
laugh because there are some funny parts
in this film it does poke
at pop culture and today's fashion
trends and when it does that sometimes
it really hits home just like the first
Zoolander it really poked a lot of fun
at pop culture fashion trends and
celebrities of that early 2000s time
period it tries to do the same thing
today but I think they went a little too
far with it there's far too many
celebrity cameos and sometimes they're
just like oh it's you oh it's you
welcome to my movie and it just became
more of a distraction than actually
funny now I expected this movie to be
really stupid because the first one is
also really stupid it's not actually
stupid it has a lot of stupid characters
so I expected this movie also to have
that and so when this film did those
things it did work for me but there's a
lot of comedy that felt very out of
place
and just not funny like a full-grown
adult actor in real life portraying a CG
little person not funny one of the
things I loved about the first Zoolander
is that it felt low-budget it felt
almost risky like they were taking
chances this film has a ton of CGI and a
lot of it is really bad this movie was a
mess it tried to incorporate a lot of
things from the first film by doing
callbacks to certain actors and some of
the best parts of the first movie and
while it was sort of nice to see some of
those things it just wasn't funny and it
was just sort of there to be there like
we're gonna do that because you liked it
the first time and we don't really have
a reason for doing it again but you
liked it the first time right for a
sequel like this to come out now this
far away from the original it has to
have a good reason for existing the
first film was about a male model
brainwashed to assassinate the Prime
Minister of Malaysia
that's an amazing plot this movies about
Derek trying to get his son back from
people in the fashion industry that's
not an amazing plot this movie didn't
really have a reason to exist and while
it does have some funny moments and the
best things I can say about it are that
it's characters that we loved from the
original films those characters are
retained like they're still good lovable
characters the characters in this movie
are not really the problem it's just the
movie surrounding them I still love
Zoolander as a character I still love
Ansel as a character they're still funny
and likeable but the movie and the
script surrounding these characters was
just not funny I'm going to give
Zoolander 2
see - guys thank you so much as always
for watching yes I am in a different
location and that's because my wife and
I just filmed our hilarious 'ti review
that's going to go up on Valentine's Day
this Sunday we decide to do it down here
because there's more room and that
review is of Twilight I can't move I
can't wait to share that with you guys
we had so much fun filming it that's
going to go up on Valentine's Day this
Sunday look forward to that very much go
see Deadpool I just saw it again for the
second time I have a little figurine
right there it was so good even better
the second time I also want to let you
guys know that my promotion with
audible.com is still going on these guys
have been amazing to me over the past
few years they've provided a lot of free
stuff for you guys and they are still
doing that through me and I thank them
very much for that they're currently
offering you guys a free 30-day trial if
you go to audible.com slash Chris there
are over 180,000 books to choose from
and I adore that site a lot of you guys
have thanked me for this giveaway and
I've been doing it over the past few
years they've been amazing thank you so
much to audible.com for sponsoring my
videos once again guys that is a free
30-day trial at audible.com slash Chris
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my nice